yasher Ali journalist published footage
from Stephen Crowder's home with his
wife because they're going through a
divorce and I don't think this should be
uh published I think yashar Ali was
wrong to publish this I don't think it
should be discussed but the issue is the
the videos got half a million views the
Tweet itself I think has two million
views so I'm interested in talking about
to a certain degree what it is because
it is a thing people are watching but
more so the ethics of why this should
not be a thing and how I think it's
being weaponized against Stephen Crowder
so to put it simply there's a few big
stories right now one you may have seen
Stephen Crowder put out a video where he
said that he's going through a divorce
it's horrendous and that he I think he
said he's being extorted is that what he
said
he implied right did he say extorted or
he said if you know what extortion is
like this is what it feels like or
something like that now the media Daily
Beast reports Stephen Crowder's
extortion war with Candace Owens it
blows up and I'm wondering how is it
that Stephen Crowder's divorce has
become some something for like yeah sure
to publish why is it news it's it's
ridiculous because I've hate Stephen
correct because the left hates Stephen
Crowder and so this is a huge
opportunity for them to attack him to
accuse him of wrongdoing and then you
get this video
this video that I'm not going to play
um I know a lot of people want me to
play it people were commenting like you
got to play the video people are mad at
Crowder dude I will not fall for a 20
second out of context clip I'm not
playing that game that's what I want to
say about this to everybody who's seen
this video you've got Stephen Crowder's
wife she's very pregnant they're arguing
I guess over a car or something like I
was surprised to learn that Crowder his
family has one car
or supposedly supposedly
exactly exactly because like when I hear
the story that Crowder's fighting with
his wife because he wants to use the car
and he doesn't want her to use the car
I'm kind of like maybe they have maybe
the other cars in the shop maybe but
Crowder seems like the kind of guy who
would have three maybe four or five cars
maybe a collection he doesn't want to
tell anyone about yeah no I mean more
you know but uh what I want to say about
the uh the video clip is a few questions
one how did yasher Ali get three minutes
of video footage of crowder quote being
emotionally emotionally abusive to his
wife Crowder's house from Crowder's
house so who is recording this they have
a ring camera in there I mean this is
crazy audio and video record in his
house and what what bothers me about
this is man I'm reluctant to say what I
think but I think Crowder is being set
up just I mean he wouldn't post that
footage right himself that means
somebody knew the footage was available
shared it with the press and
who could that have been I mean it it is
like it is possible that someone at ring
but I mean I do I think that I think I
think all right dude I'm just gonna say
it come on man who do you think his wife
yeah I think she's she he's getting
divorced so who who and he said it's
become increasingly hostile like I
wonder if this is actually something got
submitted to the court I don't want to
accuse I don't know that she did I'm
just saying Crowder in this video
he's not gonna release that footage no
if it was if it was hacked footage
either of them I would assume would be
upset by that I would say it they or
they might both say it be like hey we're
having issues but our cameras in our
home where our children we're hacked
where our children are like this is an
issue we're gonna Sue ring and it's
going to be a thing like but I don't
think that's happened never said that no
so you know I want to say something too
that's kind of crazy is people are
acting like this video is really bad and
it's it's not
so uh basically his wife says write an
impasse I love you but I need some time
and then she's she accuses him she says
something about his abuse and he says
watch it watch it and like that's
basically it and I'm like I don't know
what I'm supposed to be mad about
they're just people want to be mad they
want to be mad and it's actually
impossible to judge because you we don't
know them like we don't know them on
this level I mean it's it's something
that I think as a culture especially
women are increasingly aware of like you
need to be careful about the Dynamics
you put yourself in and like I do know
people who have been in really
controlling relationships where like
only having one car is a part of that
but I don't know the Crowders well
enough to have any context to believe
that's where this comes from right like
it's it's I think hard not to read and
you have to be careful not to read your
own experience into it like if you have
been in a dangerous situation you might
see it but if you haven't you may not it
doesn't mean like it's hard to know what
it is I remember I was I was hanging out
with some friends of mine this is
probably like six years ago and I heard
how they talked to each other and I was
like man I don't know if I I like that
I'm not gonna talk to my wife that way
and then over the years since I got to
know I'm like oh this is kind of how
they joke around with each other and say
stuff now I'm not saying that's what's
happening here but like a lot of people
especially people accommodating on this
are they married they're in a
relationship what they're talking about
yeah I I'm experience you know I'll
probably end up I'll probably get in
trouble to some degree for saying my
opinions on this because I think it's a
stupid story that shouldn't be published
but
when I see camera footage released
that's got a 20 second clip that makes
someone like Crowder look bad
and then I I'll just put it this way
if there was a recording of say like
let's say Phil Labonte was accused of
wrongdoing and then also the recording
emerges and I'm like hello there Phil
tell me about that time you bought
illegal drugs and then feels like what
are you talking about you know the
illegal drugs you bought tell me you'd
kind of assume that someone was
intending on that recording existing for
purposes of of implicating another
person so when I see this and again
Without accusing anybody because I don't
know when I see this and someone says
let me tell you about your abuse Stephen
I'm like are you what do people talk
like that like it's a very specific
thing to say to someone and then Crowder
clearly reacts negatively to it he says
watch it and then he says effing watch
it
and my response to that is like dude if
someone walks up to me in my room and
accused me of something as serious as
that I might be like excuse me no get
out like I'm not having that
conversation because that's not true
that's not fair what are you saying
worse still
somebody leaked the footage to yasher
Ali yeah
yeah I I mean anything I at this point
with the way the culture war is going
anybody that is a a prominent figure on
the right it is every opportunity that
that someone on the left can take to
cannot to knock you down or to to smear
you yeah they're going to take it's
something that people that are are oh
yeah you know that are on the right that
they have to be aware of oh okay so so
fair point people are mentioning that's
a Twitter clip there's a three minute
clip and he says a lot worse things he
says I'm gonna F you up and so you know
Fair Point like he should not have done
that right I think I haven't watched the
full thing yeah I haven't watched it I
think it's really hard because
saying really nasty things one time like
does that constitute being an abusive
person or is it just you lost control in
this one moment right like we have no
way to know what the pattern of their
relationship is and that's why it's hard
to see this stuff online because like
they have children the internet is
forever is this one terrible fight for a
couple that's already falling apart or
is this a pattern of behavior that it's
hard for the public to wrap their heads
around because he is a public figure
well this could be another issue of I
mean often not always but in
relationships it's not always just one
person at fault it can be both people
are at fault kind of like a War's
happened it's not always a good guy and
a bad guy sometimes it's just two kind
of bad guys duking it out so I I just
think that's a whole nother again
there's just not enough context to know
but I also know I mean this is maybe a
little bit of personal experiences I'm
ready for two years now being in a
position like he's in of constant
criticism under a microscope at all
times like that can put stress on a
marriage I I want to stress this too I
didn't watch the three minute I didn't
realize Joshua released the entire three
and a half minutes I watched clip on
Twitter and when I opened up the article
on my phone the video wasn't there like
I didn't see the video there until just
now so that's my mistake so I apologize
for that he snaps at her saying watch it
effing watch it I will F you up which
led to his wife fleeing their home so
like I think it's bad and I'm just I'm
like
the the issue I take with it is it's
personal private stuff if Crowder did
wrong he's paying the price for it
they're the only reason it's news is
because Crowder is a prominent figure
who's challenging The Establishment and
they know that they can they can take
him down with something like this
they've been waiting for something like
this if Crowder did something wrong in
this moment he should he should
apologize for being wrong and and doing
a wrong thing make things right to her
but the purpose of this is to cause
political and PR damage to a prominent
individual who is challenging the
machine it's just a smear it's pure
culture War it's just smearing Crowder
because he's on the right that's all it
is it's unfortunate but that's that's
the the
world and it doesn't make like the way
he's talking to her okay it just means
if he were a private citizen it would
still be wrong okay this happens
this is happening a thousand other times
in America somewhere else with other
people all over no one will know about
talk about don't care yeah they only
care because it's him and her absolutely
absolutely
sorry I just feel bad for their kids
right because like oh yeah obviously
this seems contentious and horrible
divorce is so difficult for children as
it is but like how many kids they have I
don't know do they uh well she's
pregnant yeah like there's one on the
way there's a lot of really serious
accusations in here and like my view is
just this I don't I don't care to
condemn someone because a clip even the
three minute three and a half minute one
I read the quote where he said that and
stuff like that and it's like
man
to take three minutes of someone's life
and then condemn them over that without
knowing everything else
unless there was like serious like let's
say he got up and started beating that'd
be different because then it'd be like
okay
that's like one of the issues that so
many people have about abuse like the
way people talk about abuses because
like if like someone punched me in the
face right we would all agree that's
been out okay but if you are constantly
in a place where you're like in fear
because of the way you're being treated
the way you're talking to like being
talked to stuff like that like that is
psychologically damaging it's just much
harder to analyze like in some ways we
wish abuse was more clear-cut and like
in this case like we just don't have the
context to know what's going on that's
why it's like I wish this wasn't out
here I wish we weren't we didn't have to
talk about it or address it because like
I would never
I don't think you can accurately
um prescribe what's going on from three
minutes if it is a really toxic Dynamic
I hope both of them get help and if it's
this was just a bad moment I again I
have to reiterate like they have
children this will live on forever and
that's who's suffering the most from all
of this yeah and they'll both and the
issue here too is they'll both be
bothered by it they go through with the
divorce she goes somewhere else people
will always know her as the woman in
this clip and he'll always be known as
the dude in this clip so they're they're
both screwed over it I don't see it I
don't see how there's a winner by by
releasing this uh I even if whether it
be it could help with a lawsuit
potentially or
um Divorce Court well I mean having it
would but like putting it out and it
doesn't look giving you know having yeah
I should put it out it doesn't uh it
doesn't does I don't see how how there's
any unless it's like a moment of anger
right like we really think she leaked it
and she's like the way you said your
statement makes it sound like this was
something I did and you're the victim
and I feel like I suffered I mean it's
not an okay way to handle it in my
opinion but again it's my opinion I did
not have to be involved with any of this
and I again I just think that like these
videos last forever and their kids are
going to inevitably Google themselves
and this will come up people are saying
like don't defend Stephen blah blah I'm
like bro I have seen so many video
videos from protests or of people being
who are like supposedly innocent being
beaten by cops or whatever and then the
full video comes out
and so I'm just saying like I'm not
saying Steven's perfect he probably has
to apologize for a lot okay and that's
fine but the the the fact is this is
being weaponized by people who just want
to take down Stephen Crowder for
political reasons well if all of us
examined ourselves I mean I know there
have been Knights that I've neglected my
wife not done things for her and if
there were Clips posted of me sitting at
my computer gaming and not spending time
with her people could be like whoa look
how selfish Lucas is playing video games
and not spending time with his wife
we're still how many of us are guilty of
similar things how about this what if
you were playing video games with your
wife and you're saying stuff like if I
catch you you will kill you yeah yeah
right I can't believe he said that and
it's like your wife's laughing and she's
like oh and you know exactly but context
it matters too what I don't like about
this video
is I just
the question of who leaked it yep and if
the if it was leaked is this like was
someone aware that they were having a
recording created and they said things
you know what I mean just like imagine
if you walked up to somebody who trusted
you and didn't think that you would leak
a recording of them or whatever and then
they said something to you intentionally
to make you angry that you knew wasn't
true and there's nothing you can say
like like if if I went to film was like
I know you stole my bike you'd be like
what and then you have a negative
reaction to it then someone leaks the
footage being like when Tim confronted
Phil over stealing his bike Phil freaked
out and got really angry yeah right
right wouldn't you be angry if someone
accuse you of abusing them if you if you
didn't do it you know what I mean like
I'm gonna F you up like it's not
something
I'm not saying he's innocent at all I'm
just saying like
critical thinking skills I didn't I
didn't have this even slated for tonight
until everyone was like super chatting
and asking about it and I'm like the
problem I see here is that everyone's
jumping the gun and immediately just
attacking Crowder over this and it's
like okay like I'll say it again
innocent until proven guilty it doesn't
look good but it's also none of our
business yeah is there a date on this
video I think yes I think it was uh 2021
yeah oh this doesn't make again doesn't
make the exchange better at all but like
it makes me wonder like you know if you
realize that you're in a terrible
Dynamic with someone like do you do work
do you seek out a priest or a therapist
like how do you work through these
things and like at what point like we'll
never know the context of what's going
on or what afterwards look so June 26
so so they have twins and yeah so I
don't I don't want to get too in depth
on on making uh making assumptions about
this
um because of my experience and because
of people close to me's experience with
uh
abusive partners and stuff I'm gonna
leave it at this like if you're in a
situation where you feel like you are
being abused just get out of it like
just leave
um our guitar player has passed away and
leading up to his death there was a lot
of abuse in his relationship uh
if if you're in a situation just leave
just leave doesn't worry about telling
people don't worry about stories just
get out of it I I want to add one thing
like what
I don't like seeing videos on the
internet that are like a short snippet
and then condemning someone I like
evidence to Swindle with the Covington
kids but I also am aware that the left
has this technique this trick where
they'll start filming and then they'll
go why did you just do this thing why
did you just call me this slur why did
you just hit me and you don't actually
see the thing happen you just see them
saying why did you do it and the other
person is yelling and they're like aha
here's a video of a person who did X
yeah so it's just like
sorry man what can you believe anymore
yep well apparently people are saying uh
the wife released it he said that
Crowder was lying about the situation
yeah I just I don't know why why would
the wife release it
is it because like she's not a public
figure
yeah but maybe that's what she's like
unhappy about like she feels like she
suffered and now Stephen's getting to
say like this wasn't my choice I didn't
want to get divorced and she's like you
didn't attend to our marriage the way
you should have I'm just speculating I
don't actually know I don't want to I
guess one thing that Yasha reports is
that Crowder actually got a divorce
lawyer like in advance or something but
he's I just I get the money that makes
sense to me I find it all very suspect I
really do you know Crowder Crowder is a
person that they've been desperate to
get rid of for a very very long time
he's extremely prominent and effective
when it comes to messaging and humor and
and building culture he's the only
competition for like well Gutfeld now
but for a while it was the only
right-leaning competition to late night
comedy or or like morning talk shows I
am not saying he is innocent I'm just
saying it gives me pause and makes me
you know I I'm I find it suspicious well
and there are a lot of people who have
chaotic personal lives who can do good
right like it doesn't make the messaging
and like the the entertainment value and
the things that he has done to like
introduce people to all kinds of
important ideas less valuable it just
means that he's a flawed person but so
is everyone at the end of the day
yeah but nobody it's it's tough like I
know I've mistreated people in
relationships and and even people at
work and then also my wife neglecting
her whatever and I think a lot of people
just are unwilling to acknowledge that
and they want to go judge everyone
else's lifestyle instead of going oh am
I actually making some of the same
mistakes and that I think that's a lot
of the problem and a lot of the reason
they want to go after someone like
Crowder or other people who are having
issues with their their own life is so
that they can prop themselves up and
feel good especially I'm not doing that
I think it's like no you're actually
doing that in another way you just won't
but but people are saying it's Crowder's
fault he brought this up it's like
um maybe the reason Crowder brought it
up was because his wife gave the video
footage to journalists and to Native
summons and he knew it and he was like
there's nothing I can do about it now
they're going to publish this footage so
I'll get in front of it now people are
acting like that's proof they had no
choice but to release the footage and
give a statement because Crowder brought
it up and it's like if this has been
going on for two years and Crowder
didn't say anything at all ever until
yahshua Ali like right was about like
was just about to publish the story it
kind of lends itself to they took this
move against Crowder not the other way
around yeah
is that all around yep
I don't know does this mean that you
know you guys in the chat are going to
stop watching Stephen Crowder or
something
some people probably want to boycott him
probably yeah I mean I imagine so but I
don't imagine that is I don't imagine
that is that his audience is gonna I
mean it depends on what comes out if
it's if it's bad-mouthing and fighting
and and you know bitterly arguing with
his wife people probably won't leave him
like high and dry they'll just be like
okay you were kind of crappy just so
long as it's not too grossly offensive
if it comes out that he was doing you
know other kind of things that that kind
of Cross Physical lines or whatever then
you might lose it all sure well this is
kind of going back to the first topic of
conversation with uh Budweiser
um if there if there was some stuff
going on and now this is public
for PR but I also think just from a
moral standpoint
um if Crowder just did a video going hey
I'm sorry you all had to see my personal
life and what happened yes I'm imperfect
yes I did some of these things we're now
trying to part ways as well as we can
and et cetera et cetera and he did a
video you know coming forward and
explaining the situation and apologizing
for any wrongdoing that he did because
he probably did at some level especially
I imagine if the video you know based on
the video uh I think a lot of people
would go oh okay thank you um you're
transparent you're being genuine and
real that's what they want Budweiser to
do here's what here's what I'm going to
choose to believe I'm gonna I'm gonna I
mean this as a joke by the way that uh
after Crowder came after the daily wire
Jeremy boring could stand and he's like
and then he's like pull out all the
stops it's time for my room
and then like Candace and Michael
Knowles are there and Matt Walsh and
they're like we're at your disposal
Jeremy and he's like I want dirt on this
guy whatever you can find I'm kidding
call out my buddy at uh Amazon so that
way I can get his ring camera right
like cloud-based cameras and we all
floated like was it a hack like the fact
no no apparently they're saying that uh
I guess Candace said it was the wife it
was yeah that's the simplest explanation
but I'm just anti-amazon ring cameras
and I feel like this is a good moment to
put that in there yeah I just all the
way when someone is on camera and
they're like Phil that time you struck
me was wrong and then you're like what
are you talking about don't deny it now
you're proving it and then I and then
the footage gets released and it's like
oh wow look at this Phil looks really
really bad I'm just kind of like you
know she walks up to him and she says
he's abusing her and then gives the
footage to someone it's kind of like
15 minutes ago there was a 38 Chinese
warplanes and six vessels of the
people's Liberation Army Navy detected
around Taiwan timing Taiwanese defense
Ministry says but what does that have to
do with Crowder getting divorced I don't
know
I'm sorry classic China breaking news on
a Friday by the way yeah right
I'm sorry for feels like I
where did you see that story uh inside
Insider paper they are verified uh so
that means they have eight dollars and
uh
259 fall five 259 000 followers do
people trust people more through check
marks still do you think I don't think
so yeah I don't think so now you can buy
one but also before I'm not seeing the
story it was arbitrary about who got it
like you had to be it people definitely
respected it back then like for sure but
when I was at Twitter's discretion like
if they liked you you would get one I
get that it had like a symbolic all
right this is just breaking right now 38
we're playing six vessels of people's
Liberation Army Navy detected around
Taiwan Taiwanese defense Ministry says
well I mean okay it's just it's the
waiting I can't stand so yeah
especially you know I actually thought
they would make the moves closer to the
election because it would be more
chaotic uh during elections the
president is limited in what they can or
can't do because they're so distracted
no it's not just that it's that if if if
there there's a person there's cons if
Joe Biden reacted decisively and took
action people might cheer for it but if
he screws up he's done for and it'll put
someone else in power so it ties their
hand behind their their hands behind
their back yeah well I don't know maybe
maybe we're sitting here uh talking
about stupid culture War drama nonsense
and uh China's about to invade Taiwan
world war three starting right
yeah how many times have we said World
War III started by now I think it's like
eight yeah maybe 16. thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8 pm and become a member over
at timcast.com for uncensored members
only shows exclusive thanks for hanging
out and we'll see you all next time